hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video guys i
will go through amc and gme price action
as every day during what i think is the
squeeze so we're gonna of course have a
look at what are the potential targets
where the price action could potentially
pull back as well and we're gonna go
through what happened today in after
hours so let's get into it
all right guys so i'm gonna go quickly
on the technical analysis part because
we didn't move much today
amc was down four percent i mean it's
quite small compared to the big big
moves we had in the past five ten
fifteen days uh so
it was a quiet day we can see we traded
with low volume once again for those who
watched the video i posted yesterday and
two days ago guys i was saying that the
second wave pullback is expected and
that it would be looking good as long as
we don't have big volume trading during
this second wave and as long as the
moves are not too um volatile and too
strong so the two days ago we had a
minus uh 12
so it's you know kind of brutal but
actually it's not that much once again
compared to the strong moves up we had
uh the day before plus 45
plus 44 exactly 44 45 whatever um so
today we kept correcting in the second
wave pullback which is once again very
healthy very good guys look at the rsi
the rsi is back to the
not neutral area not yet but back below
the 70 uh level which is the overbought
area
um so once again the rsi is showing you
that we have energy we are rebuilding
some energy that we will need if we
really want to push higher so uh the
levels i gave you yesterday guys are
still good to use i'm gonna in this
video show you quickly what are all the
different uh support levels we have uh
i'm not sure we're gonna see them again
i'm gonna go thread is happening in
aftermarket of course guys it's very
interesting but first uh we can use here
the feed ratios 26 23.7 and 21 okay so
the obvious support levels then we can
add on top of that some trend lines so
we have um you know the trendlines you
can use uh are based on the previous
consolidation previous highest previous
flows but here we already had a full
five wave development on the upside so
in this situation elliot2f3 is very
precious and is telling you that second
waves usually retrace to the top of the
third wave or the bottom of the fourth
wave so here the top of the
third wave is 22 and the bottom of the
force is 19 so 19 seems too far uh when
we use fields that's why i like to
associate elliot and fibs and to see
what is you know fitting the best that's
why i personally bought some shots at 26
uh because it was the 38.2 percent and
it we had a natural support at this uh
level but then we can also imagine that
we go to the 50 like we did today or
even the the 61.8 which is 21. so
between those two have 22. so i think
that 22 is a very strong support um i
don't say we're gonna go there i'm just
saying that if we go there i will
personally buy more shells
and as long as we stay above the 61.8
percent retracement of fibs uh we are in
a totally typical uh bullish development
that could occur as well here in five
waves on a bigger uh degree so one two
we're here in the second wave three four
five so i will repeat what i said
yesterday usually second waves last
between one third and half or sometimes
a full but um you know cycle of the
first wave so here the first wave lasts
two weeks so we can expect between three
days and uh one maximum two weeks of
correction for the second wave the usual
the typical situation would be two three
days so we had three days of correction
so maybe tomorrow we're gonna moon uh
and especially that we have very good
bullish momentum that is coming back
guys enough to market so i'm going to go
through jme press action right now but
basically the news came on gme it's a
news about the stock split uh that could
happen if shareholders vote for this so
uh investors didn't need more than that
to buy massively in aftermarket and amc
after uh markets was so right now you
see 24.6 and in after hours we went to
26 roughly i think 25.85 so we are back
to this uh resistance level now so let's
see if tomorrow we are able to break it
i think that if jme stays where it is so
let's go through jme press action yes
because it's very interesting and the
premium that i'm giving you guys in my
life i mean that i gave you yesterday
the day before and in my lives is right
now 20 premium for gme in if i take into
account after hours which means
that if jamie stays where it is so let's
go through dme press action but it means
that amc has 20 percent um
a 20 move up to catch up uh to be fair
with uh compared to jamie so
jimmy press action guys i'm here using a
different um scale regular scale which
gives me this triangle that you probably
have as well and as you can see we came
back as usual when we break out from
those triangles without a strong
consolidation here here we had what we
didn't have a consideration around 150
level it went just through this very
brutally so usually in these situations
we have a retest coming very quickly so
here it it happened uh it didn't even
touch i mean it depends where i put
exactly this trend line but it didn't
even touch
exactly the um this triangle upper band
we found some support on the 200-day
moving average uh that is at the 164
level today so this is a very uh bullish
sign
that is showing us that um
that that blues are just you know um
making the perfect move
that uh this small correction is totally
expected and then once again uh if we
take just a little step back step back
we are very bullish today jamie was flat
when the the rest of the market was
dropping and guys in aftermarket this is
of course what i'm sure you are all
talking about because guys maybe this is
the beginning of the third wave it looks
like it let's be honest uh this kind of
moves when there is a very low liquidity
are of course very strong because it's
easier to move the market when there is
a small volume
um
but let's check the volume by the way
yeah you can see it moved on very slow
very small volume but it's totally
normal because everyone is trading
during regular
market hours so here you can see very
soon move up on very low volume um so
for this reason this move here is i mean
less important than if it had happened
in regular market hours but it's still
very important and i'm very sure that
tomorrow we're going to open around this
area and let's see now 200 is resistance
if we break it right away guys uh the
200 so 197 level of gme is equivalent to
the 33 level of amc
so here it looks like the beginning of
the
third wave so let me do the same
analysis as i did for amc support at 160
that has been touched today but as you
can see guys jme was much stronger today
than amc so for this reason we had this
premium rebuilding 11
more for jme during market hours and in
aftermarket we went up to 20 difference
between gme and amc
um
so yeah if we use fibs guys just it's
interesting to see that the second wave
pullback just went to even didn't even
go
to the 38.2 percent uh retracement of
fibs which is usually a hit during
second wave so it shows you how strong
the move is so let's see uh i'm not
saying i'm not saying is hundred percent
sure we are able
to um to just move sorry up
to just move right away tomorrow through
the 200 level but it's very possible
because once again we had three days of
correction which is enough in this kind
of strong and impulsive moves
so if tomorrow we're able to close above
the 200 level um
this would be very certainly the
beginning of the third wave just this
third wave so then we're gonna have 250
as a resistance
uh
you can we can make different scenarios
maybe it's it's it's gonna be a first
wave extension i doubt it i doubt it can
still be the first wave so we're gonna
discuss that tomorrow depending on the
moves depending on the volume but what i
wanted to say is that if we close above
200 i don't think 250 can hold i think
we're just going to go through it
brutally uh with a lot of volume uh
short's going to start to cover in this
area probably
and i think that this third wave could
go to the 400 area then small pullback
and then 800 uh as i was expecting guys
so long ago so hopefully we're going to
do that uh in the coming month uh have
some time targets uh that you know it's
very approximative of course but you
know around maybe june maybe even before
guys it can be very quick maybe june end
of april i don't know i think we're
gonna have here at least one week of
correction during this fourth wave
pullback uh so let's see first how high
the first wave is going but the third
wave is going but what i wanted to tell
you guys today
is that gme looks very good and if gm is
able to hold around the 200 level
tomorrow or even above that
amc will have no other choice at some
point to catch up and to to to break out
above the 32 33 level that is to me the
major resistance level once this is done
uh we have to me a freeway to the 70
area we have some resistance at 44 45
but same as you can see we don't have
many reactions here we don't have
obvious trend lines so brailles are
going to be disorganized it's going to
be easier for bulls of course to go
through all these bear camps that are
not located in the same area whenever
there is a clear resistance all the
bears will be waiting there and it's
much tougher to go through it in this
situation i personally don't see any
swing resistance before 70. so my guess
is that if we're able to go through
through 32 33 we're gonna go quickly to
70 then pull back maybe to the 60 area
and then 130 which is the target so
let's see if we're able to do that uh
yeah the news i wanted to discuss the
news the news is about the stock split
so stock split is good news for
investors because they can buy at a
lower price but let's be honest this is
not a news that happened um that i mean
it's a um they want to make a vote uh
for shareholders if yes or not there's
going to be a stock split the gamestop
management wants to do that so it's just
showing you that investors don't need
much today to really jump and buy so
it's a very good sign of bullish
momentum and that's enough for me i
don't really care about the news but
once again a stock split is good for
investors because it's easier for small
investors to buy shares but once again
this is not a very massive news to me uh
but it's a very good sign of the bullish
momentum that we're having right now gme
is trading in aftermarket guys at
192 so as you can see in aftermarket
resistances still work uh we
have some resistance around okay we went
slightly through this level 100 and
uh
even 200 something i don't see well 202
i think um and we came back
a little bit below that so i think that
we're gonna open around this area
tomorrow and once again um it looks very
much like the third wave is starting so
let's see uh i will personally be buying
some calls on amc tomorrow morning uh
hopefully i'm gonna have the opportunity
to get some at a good
level if we stay in this area i don't
think we're gonna open with 20 up on amc
but i'm very sure that if jamie opens 20
up up and stays there amc is going to
catch up during the day so that's why
for me tomorrow the easy trade to do is
buy amc um so this is what i'm gonna do
not financial advice and of course guys
this is uh very hard to predict i know
there are a lot of youtubers out there
trying to you know price as well uh what
could happen the different levels i'm
doing that guys for some time it's not
easy i'm gonna keep doing it but just
keep in mind that no one knows what can
really happen we are all trying to make
our scenarios and to uh you know um
and to adapt our orders compared to
those uh
in to be in line with those scenarios
but the truth is that no one knows what
can happen i'm very bullish yes i've
always been uh for in the long term and
i think that we are coming to this major
squeeze event so let's see guys i'm very
excited for the coming days coming weeks
i'm going to be with you as much as i
can uh at least one video a day i'm
going to try to do some live as well but
i'm going to book as the tour guys
during the weekend so you know i'm gonna
have also some free time there but i'm
gonna be here to make one more video
during the weekend so i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys